aujourd'hui on va parler d'une image
choisie par joël chandeliers et grâce à
son travail on va comprendre comment
l'église nous montre que la foi et la
raison peuvent être compatibles
[Musique]
voici un tableau devant lequel on ne
s'attarde pas souvent quand on visite le
louvre où il est conservé aujourd'hui
peut-être parce qu'il est trop compliqué
un peu confus ou parce qu'il est trop
médiévale il s'appelle le triomphe de
saint thomas d'aquin
il est l'oeuvre d'un peintre italien de
la renaissance bender götze au lit elle
a été réalisée vers 1470 le travail est
divisé en trois parties superposés en
eau le christ
il bénit de sa main droite et les rayons
du soleil qui émane de lui montre sa
protection
il est entouré de six fondateurs du
christianisme moïse saint paul et les
quatre évangélistes matthieu marc luc et
jean dans le deuxième tiers on trouve
thomas d'aquin en majesté au centre de
la composition comme le veut son statut
ce moine dominicain du xiiie siècle
porte une auréole
mais les rayons qu'il diffuse autour de
lui parts des livres qu'il a sur les
genoux on y lit une citation de la bible
est un extrait de son propre ouvrage la
somme contre les gentils qui est un
traité de théologie qui a pour but
justifier la foi catholique contre les
infidèles
dans la troisième partie du tableau et
représenter une assemblée de moine
prêtres évêques et cardinaux à gauche le
pape est plus haut et plus grand que
tous les autres semblant guider la
discussion sur un livre qu'il tient sur
ses genoux
malgré cette disposition hiérarchique
plutôt classique message du tableau
n'est pas si simple et joël chandelier
nous l'expliquent déjà tous les
personnages portent des livres des
évangélistes aux hommes d'église en
passant par thomas en plus de ça comme
dans une bulle de bande dessinée on peut
voir jésus dira en latin coma a bien
écrit sur moi pour comprendre ce message
il faut s'attarder un peu autour sur le
tableau à côté du personnage on peut
voir les deux plus grand philosophe grec
aristote à gauche et platon à droite et
en dessous allongé sous thomas d'aquin
c'est averroès l'un des plus grands
philosophes arabes
s'il est là c'est pour une bonne raison
averroès ce n'est pas un philosophe
quelconque
c'est un grand commentateur d'aristote
et de platon qui est souvent considéré à
l'époque comme sulfureux selon l'église
et les mêmes coupables d'avoir voulu
montrer que la vérité de la raison de la
philosophie et de la science serait
contraire à la doctrine de la foi en
étant allongé ici
sa pensée est littéralement piétinés par
thomas d'aquin qui lui a su réconcilier
les enseignements du christ en haut avec
ceux des philosophes payen à ses côtés
pour les transmettre à l'église en
dessous lui pour jouer le chandelier le
message est donc clair foi et raison ne
sont pas incompatibles comme semblez le
penser averroès au contraire grâce à
thomas d'aquin les deux peuvent se
réconcilier et fournir à l'humanité une
pensée qui est en même temps rationnel
scientifique et religieuses l'idée que
cette pensée devait ensuite être
transmises par l'église n'est pas propre
moyen âge et en 1879 le pape léon xiii
fait de la philosophie de thomas d'aquin
la doctrine presque officielle de
l'église en matière de philosophie
averroès n'est plus considéré comme un
danger pour la fois mais la question du
rapport entre la science et la religion
reste toujours aussi actuelle
aujourd'hui qu'elle l'était au moyen-âge
merci à jouer genre d'heuliez qui nous a
permis de faire cette vidéo et à bientôt
sur une image une histoire
[Musique]